[Music]
I don't think I've ever seen a Disney
Channel movie I was more ready to like
than don't look under the bed from its
Sam Raimi style POV shot from its cool
shadow work to the fact that the main
character is named Francis Bacon good
lord I am gonna fall in love with this
but the more the movie continued the
more bizarre it got and kind of the more
awkward a god that's not to say there
isn't a lot of cool stuff about it but
there's also a lot of dumb stuff about
it and in the end it's kind of a mess a
teenage girl named Francis Bacon cot it
feels so weird to say it skipped ahead
of grade in school and the only reason I
bring that up is because the movie
brought up it actually doesn't play much
into anything but what does is all sorts
of weird things are happening around the
area Klotz are being set for where cars
are being egged and even people are
stopping directly in their tracks in
silence it's actually kind of the most
eerie part of the movie because there's
no goofy music no silly acting it's just
quiet for a Disney Channel movie that's
pretty eerie things get even stranger
when Francis starts to see a boy named
Larry Houdini but nobody else seems to
nobody knows what seems to be going on
in town but Francis is instantly being
blamed
mostly because graffiti of the letter B
is everywhere except on her locker that
is it's on the inside of her locker
where only she could get to it other
things like the swimming pool being
filled with jello I love that and all
the jello from her house being gone
start to add up and start to get people
pointing fingers at her the more and
more she gets blamed for the more and
more she sees that Larry Houdini kid so
she finally confronts him and he admits
he's an imaginary friend well not her
imaginary friend has an imaginary friend
in general kids can apparently see him
but grown-ups can't his theory is that
all these pranks are being caused by the
boogeyman somebody who used to be an
imaginary friend but when somebody stops
believing they turn into an evil force
sauce up to Francis and Larry to figure
out if the boogeyman is real how they
stop him and more important how to get
her kid brother back who's kidnapped in
the third act by a giant sock that he
can't get out of and she can't get him
out of oh he also uses a spiderweb net
that looks like the easiest thing to get
out of and yet she can't get out that
either oh and the little brother had
leukemia and he got better because
the other brother gave him some of his
bone marrow if that sounds like an
afterthought it's because the film kind
of treats it that way to leukemia really
I mean you can tackle this if you want
but you never see the kid in the
hospital you never hear the kid talk
about it every once in a while someone
just brings it up as if that's why the
kid doesn't see imaginary friends
anymore well okay if you're gonna just
name drop leukemia like that you don't
really have it as a side thing you have
it as a little bit more of a focus I
mean it's freaking leukemia in the
Disney Channel movie but sadly a lot of
it is just Larry trying to convince
Francis that he's real and the boogeyman
is real and imaginary friends are real
and for whatever reason she never
believes it even though he proves it
over and over and over she still doesn't
catch on and it's so infuriating on top
of that their acting is kind of OneNote
at first they seem okay Francis is
obsessed with logic and proving things
so it makes sense that she wouldn't
believe there's an imaginary friend but
even at the end when her brother is
about to be thrown off a cliff she still
keeps that cynical delivery come on
show a little bit more emotion Larry
gets pretty annoying too at first I kind
of dug the fact that he was kind of wild
and weird because nobody saw him except
kids so he would kind of be this way but
a little of him goes really far and
after a while it doesn't feel like he's
being very natural like this is just
what this character is like it feels
like he's always trying to get a laugh
and it's usually not working the times I
like him best is when he has to talk
serious because it's delivery it's still
so strange but it's still kind of unique
I actually can't Doug it and if I was a
kid yeah maybe I get more into his goofy
stuff there's kind of a young Jim Carrey
wannabe style in there but as an adult
it gets really old really quick and it
would have been nicer if they had
something that both kids and adults
could have a lot of fun with all the
other characters are a little off too
and not really in a charming way just
kind of a weird way the father for
example I don't know what his deal is he
always kind of seems angry or maybe not
maybe he's just kind of weird I can't
really figure him out so okay it seems
like I'm crapping on this movie a lot
but to its credit there is a lot of cool
stuff as well visually it's a lot of fun
the angles in this are just so cool all
of them are kind of
and moving around warped and weird some
scenes in this I think would be
legitimately scary to little kids and
even got a little bit of a creep factor
out of me
well Larry gets angry his I suddenly go
purple and green and his voice changes
then it comes right out of nowhere
I was aren't you kind of hoping maybe he
was gonna be the villain but it doesn't
go that angle Dingle does go it's kind
of clever with a twist behind who the
actual boogey man is but even then I
don't entirely follow it so there's just
other boogeyman's that come from other
imaginary friends I mean a lot of people
don't believe in imaginary friends after
a while in fact most people and what
those are all the pranks that happen in
the world maybe why is it just this one
imaginary friend that turns into a
boogeyman that's wreaking havoc in the
town should there be like a ton of these
boogeyman but like I said every time it
doesn't make sense or it gets really
boring trying to convince her that
boogie men are real and everything they
do something kind of cool for example
when they do finally go under the bed
there's this giant weird Kingdom and
just look at this set look at these
designs these are really neat I also
love the idea of how she gets to this
world look it seems like she's climbing
under the bed but suddenly she's
climbing up a mountain in the exact same
shot that's really clever
but unfortunately you gotta wait a long
time for scenes like that and you got to
sit through a lot of uncomfortable
awkward moments to get to them I guess
it's a kid I would probably like it
though I feel like I would get bored
pretty quickly of all the talking and
would want to see a lot of the stuff
they're talking about like I said every
time they bring up that leukemia thing
it's really uncomfortable and odd it
would have gotten the point across so
much more if they actually showed a
little bit maybe you could open with
that like the kid in the hospital and
the sister feeling bad and then like you
see in that moment she had to grow up
and he had to grow up just a little
something but we get none of that here
the only bits we do get it's an
occasional smart line for example I like
when they're in the garage and Francis
said if the brother didn't believe in
the imaginary friend anymore why did he
stay - which Larry said he still needed
me it's actually kind of interesting and
can be taken a lot of ways one of the
final lines is also kind of brilliant I
guess it takes a lot of
becoming food again in a story like this
that's surprisingly profound and it
didn't mean much just a line or two but
like I said everything is either over
talked or not talked about enough it's
like the focus is always in the wrong
place if I was a kid I would probably
like chunks of it the darker stuff I'm
sure Larry would probably get a laugh
out of me too but I don't know if I
would have watch it a lot as again I'd
had to wait for quite a bit to get to
those moments if you grew up loving it
fair enough I can see why I guess but
for me this clutter under the bed is
just a little too messy
[Music]